fue un actor clave en Sudán como
mediador entre las partes en conflicto
había sido nombrado enviado especial de
la ONU al país en 2021 pero el jueves en
un comunicado el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de Sudán dijo que
el gobierno había notificado al
secretario general de la ONU que había
declarado a volcartes personandongrata
el jefe del ejército sudanés el general
abdelfata ya le había pedido que
dimitiera hace unas semanas volker
vertex había criticado a ambas partes
del conflicto por no respetar los
acuerdos de alto al fuego
en el acuerdo que firmaron hace dos días
deben de tener los combates deben
permitir el acceso de la ayuda
humanitaria a proteger a los
trabajadores y bienes humanitarios y
permitir El Paso seguro de los Civiles
para que abandonen las zonas de
hostilidades
el ejército sudanés está enzarzado en un
conflicto con las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido para militares desde el 15 de
abril los médicos dicen que los combates
han matado a más de 860 civiles pero es
probable que las cifra real sea mucho
mayor los violentos enfrentamientos han
reducido la capital a un campo de
batalla urbano durante meses grandes
partes de la ciudad no han tenido agua
corriente ni electricidad con informes
generalizados de saqueos y violencia
sexual